i only speak the truth what are things
you don't like about yourself what do
you think are your most obvious
character defects uh
like
probably i tend to be pretty selfish
because i was raised
mostly as an only child because my half
sister was out of the house so
yeah and like being very needy and
possessive over friends and people i'm
dating and
those are you still have those character
defects yeah oh yeah i a lot of my
friends say have come a long way but i
definitely still feel them because
you've had squabbles with other
comedians have i not squabbles but with
you know
i don't know if i said you pass me the
water please which one this one okay
well they've just been like you've been
friends with a comedian and then there's
been a fight and then
i don't i wouldn't say that we were
friends and there was a fight i would
say that there are people that i don't
get along with and try to avoid
and like for a while you think like oh
because i do the same thing as this
person we have to all be friends and
hang out and then you mature and realize
like actually i don't like this person's
behavior so i'm just gonna not hang out
with them ah that's what it is maybe
that yeah you're right which i think is
totally fine and i don't think that
means that i'm bad or that person's bad
or any of those people are bad i just
think it's like oh well
i'm not i don't know i like people who
are a little more humble and a little
like less self-obsessed even though i
tend to be selfish i don't think i'm
self-obsessed self-obsessed yeah
i mean i know that you know i could just
name right now who doesn't like me
right
vince vaughn yeah we've talked about i
know that i'm just throwing it out there
yeah christopher titus
i didn't do anything to the guy he just
hates he thinks he doesn't like me yeah
isn't it kind of empowering to just be
able to say that it almost makes them
look stupid because it's like why the
[ __ ] don't you like that like i don't
know why it's fine you don't have to
like me you know i i i don't know
anything i think that's a character
defect
um to
to be kind of a people pleaser and to
always want to be yeah yeah that is just
the most unrealistic thing you can ever
ask and there are people who constantly
seek that yeah and will kind of preserve
themselves into who they think that
person will like more like
it's uh
yeah those are the dangerous types i
think people pleasers are probably one
of the most dangerous types of people
well also just like i i can't imagine
that that's anything but just being in a
prison where you're like oh my god
you're at the whim of everyone around
you basically yeah you know what mitzi
shore once told me
i swear to god she told me i just back
in the early like mid 90s i met mitzi
and my friend freddy soto used to drive
a limo and you should drive mitzi around
freddy soto by the way anyone listening
is one of the funniest stand-ups i've
ever seen he passed away but he is one
of the funny looking but he's had
specials he's one of the funniest guys
ever
okay by the way
but uh missy told me once she goes you
know you know what makes a star
i go what she goes
you have to have half the audience love
you
and have half the audience hate you
at the same time
that's crazy and i go and i thought
about that
right so it's like if you try to like
get everyone to like you right it's just
like oh there's only a couple of stars
in the world that have that
and they're enigma like tom hanks
i've never heard anyone go i hate that
guy
actually [ __ ] forrest gump i bet you
there are because no probably probably
are jennifer lawrence everyone used to
think she was the apple of everyone's
eye and i think that you know even t
swift yeah you know this but you look at
somebody like roseanne barr
divisive
you know jim carrey
like half people like people hate you
all the whole time hated him from
beginning to end he's so broad that he
fought him you know i mean hate you know
i think i think that it's really good to
have people not like you
and have enemies
because you're doing something
i've had people call in when i've done
radio and said i just think that you're
awful
oh you don't have it with me and nick
youssef what it was unbelievable
believable i was in orlando okay
where the tragedy happened
so let's moment of sight but then what
happened was years ago
oh here's another oh okay i have two i
thought i'm just going to say that
check it out
i was in orlando at the improv and i
couldn't get the back door to open
you know to get to the green room
so i had to go around but as i'm going
around right
i heard um a lady like talk about
each poster that's on the wall that she
couldn't see me me and nick youssef
so she went to gabriel glacier's photos
i love him right i just wanted to hear
what she said because i know she was
going down the line oh my god d.l
hughley he's the best then she got to
mind headshot right and she goes
this guy right here is the [ __ ] worst
this lady
he is the [ __ ] i hate him
he's not funny and then nick and i walk
so that she can see us she goes i'm so
sorry when she saw me
and i just smiled
because i know that that's you know not
a bad thing
but did you really smile were you dying
no i was complaining for three hours but
after that i thought about it i know you
and then when i was the way you were
but can i say this and i didn't know
this but when i was in arlington
virginia two weeks ago
a lady came up to me and she goes
i used to go to virginia tech you
performed there
and i go
oh yeah i completely forgot i go when
did i perform there like two weeks
before cho songwei oh
geez
wow speaking of um colleges do you
perform at colleges so no no i never
have so the university of chicago bless
chicago for this basically put out a
statement to all parents of incoming
freshmen saying like look we're not
going to coddle your children we're not
going to do these um trigger warnings
and they're going to be exposed to some
things they're going to be uncomfortable
with they don't agree with and that's
probably going to like you know shock
them but we're not going to coddle them
anymore
isn't that [ __ ] great that people are
actually standing up to the fact that
like a bunch of these college kids are
just turning into these god-awful
[ __ ]
like that's why like no one wants to no
comedy comedians want to perform at your
colleges colleges used to be the best
thing in the 80s what do you mean like
doing no in the 70s and 80s like people
wouldn't want to perform
at colleges because that was where you
would get
open thinkers free free thinkers you
know
a lot of liberals people with different
ideas extreme ideas sometimes
and you would perform and um but now
it's so pc
i did a show in what was that new
hampshire or some
some some play like that and
the next day they wrote an article
saying that bobby lee perpetuates rape
culture oh yeah
i don't ha i don't have a singer he
doesn't have a single rape rape joke in
my act what yeah
and then i literally was livid and i
said i called my age i go that's it
no more colleges
for instance like now teachers are
required because you know like college
professors they're not safe unless they
have tenure right which they have to be
in the game for a certain amount of time
but previous to that they can get no
they cannot get rehired they can get
fired anything anything that they you
can't be a boat rocker in your early
years of teaching you cannot rock the
boat you can't you can't have a student
complain about you so for instance even
reading something like the great gatsby
the trigger warning is always you're
gonna be exposed to misogyny and the
idea of like um
i don't know like let's say assault
there has to be now college students are
demanding that there are warnings before
they read a book they watch a movie
before anything that they're exposed to
anything that they could possibly
dislike they want a warning wow
isn't that [ __ ] crazy so weird
especially like i was just in college i
don't know like seven years ago how is
it that different all of a sudden it is
very different so a lot of people like
some 28 mostly 28 year olds don't even
have have zero
relatability to kids who are 24 who just
got out of college like they can't
relate to those kids and it's only like
a four year gap
because of the like just the difference
in culture and for instance like george
and i were talking about like
microaggressions they teach this in
college where a simple question like hey
like where are you from is now we're
supposed to take that offensively we're
supposed to take that as oh you're not
being racially or culturally sensitive
to me
and what you're saying it's the liberals
fault right
yeah it's not
it is it is it's both it's
no
so everything is to be taken as hostile
and derogatory like here here's an
example of some microaggression
questions for you guys
when you say
no but stop my stop stop i'm gonna tell
you why now i know we talked about this
[ __ ] a month ago or you were right in
that i saw your side of it no no i'm not
a mic i feel like an idiot because you
explained your side better before i can
talk no no but i'm going to say this why
is i already gave you the example right
of me doing a naka conference right and
all the religious schools
walked out of my shell and the liberal
schools stayed
okay
they're more open-minded
yeah they are
you're right because look they stand on
the right side of social justice but
they're on the wrong side of actual
freedom of speech
they're they're on the right side when
it comes to gay rights and women you
know
like wage gaps and things of that sort
but in terms of freedom of speech you're
not allowed to say [ __ ] if you're a
hyper liberal
like you
everything offends you george is right
for instance this is one of them even if
you say
if you say something like this is a
microaggression a perfect example oh i'm
sorry i'm sorry i just get really ocd
about that type of stuff that's you
being insensitive to someone possibly
having a mental illness and they can
they can report you for a
microaggression that's just insanity
that's afraid it's just like i'm sorry
i've never even heard of that i'm so
adhd about this oh wow esther that's
that's i've never heard of it but the
thing is
baby i've never heard of that
professor there's a professor from like
north carolina who actually created this
a list of microaggressions that we're
supposed to take as hostile and
derogatory so a lot of these kids are
now thinking they're victims of these
aggressions
i've never heard of it so i don't know
that's so crazy i mean all i feel like i
can do about that is just continue to be
me and if someone does accuse me of that
just be like you're that's the way you
feel then this conversation should end
that's how i am too it's like it's like
listening to mommy
but ideologue
and esther is a i mean i'm gonna say
this i like to give people props where
they deserve it
you i'm gonna be honest with you there
has been no one like you
in the stand-up comedy world i don't
know if that's a good thing but um
but there has been no one like you
in the 20 years that i've been doing
stand up you know what even from an
outsider's perspective
you have a very very specific and
particular
voice and look and overall image
compared to
anyone else and i think that's you know
such a great advantage for you just
because you're
odd
you're not not in a way that like you're
like
jeffrey dahmer no you're not jeffrey
you're more like no you're like andrew
cunanan no it's like um
filipino
you know like back in the day when
they're starting the circus yeah like a
circus freak no no no no
no not a circus freak
i was a girl that never ages but i also
want to say that you're young and i you
know why i also love you is is that
we're you're very neurotic like i am
you get diarrhea all the time no i don't
ester my boyfriend does yeah oh my god
don't say that but he does
i'm the opposite i get constipated oh
really yeah because he told me once your
boyfriend oh my god i don't care
he told me once he takes um
what's up omodium 80 before meals just
in case i know which makes me
okay imagine thinking about every meal
and just in case you're gonna get
diarrhea that's living life in a prison
no he's being safe
it's like putting a cork in it so that
it never exactly like wearing a condom
but like he should address what is the
problem it's probably ibs yeah if it
just goes through him each time speaking
of what is the problem kalyla maybe you
should come over
maybe i should ask her our relationship
is very strange that's true yeah because
kalila's a nurse
it's strictly a nurse patient
relationship if you go through the whole
the history of our text messages it's
just a bunch of pictures of esther's
rashes
the inside of her mouth yeah like her
tonsils yeah her ct scan
i stopped watching photos i mean he's
like esther i got one i can't i don't
want to deal with her she'll text me
from new zealand i think i'm dying yeah
yeah what do i have
oh my gosh i was there for that one what
kind of rashes do you get i get all
sorts of rashes i well when i was in new
zealand i had a swollen lymph node
kaleilas helped me so much
like i
i don't even know where to start but
there's so many like she's just so good
and reliable that i keep coming back
yeah she is
she's very reliable like knowing her has
made my life significantly better oh
that's really nice you're you're a touch
hyper control but i think you know that
i do i do and i feel like i'm very aware
when i'm texting you like i'm like i
know this is crazy
yeah hopefully i say that and when i
when i was switching over phones and i
was like hey like sorry i didn't reply
back to your phone my phone's broken she
was like okay make sure you have a phone
soon a new phone soon like it was a
legitimate concern first
just in case like a new rash
one day where i'm like i don't know how
to join clubs
online
i don't know how to listen i don't know
how to participate in the online world
because i'm old so one day i went like
okay what is um
prime time what's it called
amazon prime time
i'm gonna get amazon prime i go i do it
and it's like no you can't do it through
this app you have to go to this other
app sign up for that you have to go
online i go to the other line no you
have to do this other
amazon horizon and then you know fill
out give all the information and i would
do that for three hours you remember
right
and also anything that i order i have
[ __ ] two skate shirts
like you know caballero um bone skate
shirt that i ordered four months ago
there's some it's not even here there's
someone in this neighborhood who has
three thousand dollars worth of toys
t-shirts and groceries yeah and have a
narrow sauce i tried all of it
i've tried i spent thousands of dollars
they just don't arrive at the house so
i'm doing it wrong oh my god one time
esther there's this one time and i'll
never forget this for the rest of my
life
and i'm so glad that my niece juliana
was there to witness this whole meltdown
but basically
he
decided we were on our way to the post
office because i had to mail stuff and
he threw a tantrum about what a [ __ ] i
was for not helping him out with his
prime time
because he couldn't sign up for amazon
prime and then the whole way down he was
just
in a rage meltdown and and and i told
him because i think i don't know what it
was i was like can we wait till we're
done with the windy hills for me to set
your account up because i get dizzy when
i read my phone and which put him into a
deeper rage because she did it in spite
she could have done it then no and i was
like well wait till the bottom of the
hill don't wait for the bottom of the
hill and then we'll park and i'll i'll
fix your prime time for you yeah and no
remember so i do remember that and i
called you profession i apologize
profusely but what i'm saying to you is
that the reason why i asked now for a
freezer and other things is because i am
unable to do it i don't have the
capabilities or the
you know ability to
to order things do you
sleep in a bassinet
what's a bassinet for babies babies
that's my dream
this is like i just what are you saying
are you calling me a baby no
why why'd you say do i sleep in a
basketball no let me explain i think two
things one yeah you have it you have it
so good because you have him completely
dependent on you
he can't even step into the real world
without you so you're like you own him
and you have it good because you have a
full-time caregiver so when did you let
me let's talk about your special so when
did you um film your special we shot it
in october we did four shows and then we
did i shot behind the scenes stuff with
my parents over the summer and then some
in the fall
um and then
yeah and so you shot the special for
what'd you shoot in chicago no we shot
it at dynasty typewriter in l.a oh it's
like a very small cute theater cool yeah
so you did a dynasty typewriter and then
you filmed it for comedy central and now
it comes out for a long time but i also
know her previous boyfriends oh boy
tony henchcliff
right yeah we love names here by the way
yeah
you used to eat your butthole huh yeah
yes sir go back to the mic answer that a
lot of guys have eaten my body yeah
that's the thing i've heard it's not
it's a great vibe do you ask for it no i
don't ask for it it just happened you
know you do have a look if i were a guy
i'd probably go for your [ __ ] what is
it because you're a child you look like
yes that's what it is it's a child it's
like you you look like you i should
violate you
because you're so pure and innocent
looking that would probably go for the
grossest thing first yeah you know
cheeks probably look like marshmallows
yeah i'm you don't mean like like
publishing white and round yeah correct
yeah yeah that's the first the first
weekend that i met you the first thing
she said to me she's like do you want to
see my boobs and she just showed me
really yeah
that was our bonding moment i was like
oh i like this girl that must have been
because i liked your boobs and just
wanted to see yours probably but yeah i
never showed you mine you just showed me
yours it was a one-sided
report there
one of my favorite bobby memories is
when i was at the comedy store and you
were upstairs
by the old office with russell brand and
i walked in the room and like got scared
and walked out and then afterwards
you're like why didn't you come over i
would have introduced you to him and
then you told me that i had the social
skills of an 18th century ghost
yes
because russell i think he said
i think rose what was that
i know that was a human being no it was
a ghost
no russell because russell what also
brand would do is he would like candles
around in a room and have to do like i'm
not kidding you one hour meditations
before he did this 15-minute spot
you know which is that's how he does it
that's fine everyone has their own
ritual right but when you came in and
out right it took him out of his like
you know meditation
right and so he saw what something white
in his peripheral vision
right and he thought it was a ghost and
i had to convince him that it was esther
to stand up yeah
did you ever end up meeting him no i
didn't yeah you [ __ ] up it's fine but
it was nice to be that you offered that
he's a good dude you're a good person
and then i also love
well no i want to get back into your
butthole i'm sorry
i want to get back i want to get you
back
so when they don't ask to eat your
butthole and they just dive right in you
don't say no or you like it why would i
say no and no i okay i don't like it i
don't have like a strong opinion on it
my thoughts like hey if we're we're at
this point where we're both doing these
things like not you know we're we're
naked in a bed together like
just do it whatever you know yeah and
you do do make you pretend you like like
ooh you see no i don't really pretend i
like anything i'm pretty
i feel like lately
over the years i feel like i'm starting
to realize i'm just like i lie there and
just whatever happens like like a ghost
when they penetrate you do you feel
things
or are you numb i don't get it are you
like weird yeah morrissey like you're
asexual i mean you're into it right yeah
i guess okay i don't know i'm just was
just like yeah it's sex stuff is
happening now
she's like a kid i guess sex stuff is
happening i guess sex stuff is happening
yeah and so that's actually the thing i
feel the most guilty about is that we
don't watch things together because i
feel like we should be but i just we
don't want to watch the same things why
why do we have to do you get the um
sometimes i feel like there are things i
absolutely have to watch alone in order
to um
fully um
how do i say um absorb yeah like there
are things where i'm like i i really
can't have you watch this with me
because i feel like he might paint the
experience
so
like if it's anything like he hates
anything lovey-dovey like even if it's a
really cool love story he hates all of
it he doesn't like
love stories in like a traditional sense
like two people kissing he's out he's
checked out so do you feel like if
you're watching that with him you'll be
so aware of how he's feeling you won't
be able to yeah yeah so like when when
for instance when jules and i will watch
like an old giuliana my name is oh yes
yes she's staying here yeah she's
thinking
because love stories are not real no
it's so fantasy-like but we have to hide
it we pause it when he comes back
upstairs and we won't watch it until he
leaves the room
because he can always he'll cut he'll do
drive watch that [ __ ] and they go oh
that's what love is
it's it's so romantic
did you hate brokeback mountain
i never saw it really i i couldn't see
it it was slow it's not just that i i
don't know
what
i don't know why but i just couldn't see
it that's why he hates cowboys no i i no
that's not it i i don't know remember
what it was
but i just didn't want to watch it and
you're afraid your dick would get hard
that's [ __ ] you okay let's watch it and
then i hold your dick all right
all right
oh you know what i will watch it look
i'll hover it over your dick and if i
even feel a little tip yeah yeah all
right then i'll know the truth all right
so with brokeback mountain at the time
when that came out i was really not
doing well
in life
and um i didn't have access to it i
don't you know
so i just went i went i'll pass on that
you know
but because i think at the time i had to
go to a movie theater to watch it i was
gonna buy it i don't know why
but you know um i want to watch it
because i don't have a problem with gay
love on television or film but you have
a problem with straight love
that's the point i was getting at wait
is bro back button two guys that are
straight no hooking up well they're
married oh you're you're you're married
you're talking about straight no what i
don't like is when i was growing up
right little girls would be conditioned
to believe that that's my knight in
shining armor
[Music]
like my beautiful wedding yeah it's
beautiful those aren't the type of
rom-coms that i want i don't actually it
all feeds into that what i like is you
know tragedy yeah i love tragedy
you know like what like in dr zhivago at
the very end of the movie you ever see
dr zhivago no is he the doctor that
kills people no
that's kevorkian
it's a different doctor yeah i love dr
hmo yeah it was a movie called
i think made in the 60s it was a just a
sweeping romantic
epic of a movie but at the end of the
movie you know he loses contact i guess
with his lover dr zhivago does
and for
20 years you know he doesn't know where
she is because it was a war that they
were separated
and when he's like an 80 year old man
i guess he's on a bus
and he sees
his lover three seats in front of him
so he gets up and she gets off of the
bus he gets off the bus too
and he's right behind her and he's
trying to tap her on the shoulder like
and he misses he has a heart attack he
dies and she doesn't even notice and
just she goes around the corner
that's love
see here's here's my problem with
history
he finds he gets these like
movies or shows that are not about love
at all but he'll somehow justify it as
love
in a really complex way
so that
when i have an issue in the relationship
about oh like we're not showing each
other that much affection he'll be like
well
if you look at dr zhivago like he'll
find like
he'll look at logic
if you remember saving private ryan and
then he'll take he'll twist it so that
it matches what he wants to do in a love
setting which is
not love like he doesn't want to show um
um you know the usual type of love he
doesn't want to express it in in a in a
what he calls a common way right does
that make you uncomfortable it's like
something like that i'm like i i get
what you i get it a little bit i i i
don't think you guys do i think um you
like micho black like that kind of love
no that's too rom kami for that's even i
love nico blacks that's like fantasy
that's what i'm talking about meet that
i mean that's a little hollywood version
of what i'm talking about yeah but i
love meet joe black that's what it is at
the end they can't be with each other
yeah oh so that's you know it doesn't
like happy endings so is it like house
like what are you saying that you're in
love with someone else and the fact that
you're with kalila that's like
he hopes that i die somewhere along the
way
and that he because it's not a it's not
a reality
it's not a reality you know but you like
the pain
i look i think i i i identify with that
kind of pain romantic pain yes yeah yes
yeah i love um
listening to sad music
i remember being a young man
listen to sad music rolling down the
blinders
on my day off
right sitting in a room
with because back then you could smoke
in your room
i would smoke cigarettes drink coffee
listen to super depressing music and
just ponder life sit there and smoke are
you emo
no i but that's emo it's not weird that
like then you say all that but you're
also a stand-up comedian
like you sit in sadness but you are your
job is laughter it's so weird it's like
why are why are we all like that
because um
at a point where i was sitting there
when you live like that
there comes to a point where you go uh
oh in this society
you know you there's only two ways to do
it it's either stay in that
right and then with our way
or then you have to join
you know i mean
society and sign up
for life
right are you like and so i'm like i'll
sign up for life i guess
because i can't
i couldn't bear my parents
disappointment yeah i couldn't bear
i also i had like a lot of resentment
toward high school
friends
who all went to school and they were all
gonna become senators and [ __ ]
in my head you know god you got you
you guys are like a power couple then
because you guys are both talented i
love him so much who's your favorite
power couple you guys
you think but for real though but like
aside from us like they're everybody has
their faces stop for a second oh i'm not
we're not that powerful baby let's keep
it i know i know but can i say this yeah
i'm not [ __ ] kidding you when i go on
the road now right where's kalila boom
every [ __ ] night
30 times a night
where's kaleila where's club did she
come did she come did you come so in my
opinion you are a powerful we are people
i just like to infiltrate your identity
so like the next girl after me will
always have to deal with that
can i tell you something i love that
that that's great it's amazing
that's brilliant i get you
what do you mean by that i just need her
to struggle
past
like the association between the i will
always have with you like she can never
be tiger belly she's gonna hate the fact
that we did hundreds of episodes
together yeah and then everyone will
always associate the both of us i never
had to deal with that with you you've
only dated girls like for one year at a
time we've been together for years it's
true you've met my other girlfriends i
don't know if i ever actually met them
but i just know that it was not this
long yeah yeah this is a over three
years now yeah over three yeah do you
think we'd be good parents yeah oh god
you guys are raising animals yeah well
for too many
poor it's chaos but do you do you feel
do you understand what i'm saying though
where it's like you don't want the next
girl yeah you definitely want to mark
your territory like in every way
possible you also want to make sure that
the past girlfriends don't have any
like
you know they're they don't exist
anymore i remember when we first started
jesus when we first started dating when
i i moved in with dave and he in his his
old girlfriend
had lived there before and this was like
i that was really hard for me to handle
and i remember like when i moved in i
was going through she had like these
jars of beans and i just remember like
burning them
i just didn't wait but i was like i
would always call her the old witch i'm
like the old witch is gone
wow
yeah i just women do that
we do that i mean i'm also though very
possessive clangy jealous obsessed like
i'm just that person are you i don't
know i'm very needy yeah i don't know i
think that i had to
all the things you want in a girl i was
all of those
you can't be that way with him i think
that he's so he has an aversion to that
type of like clingy there's no way to be
clingy with bobby right so in the
beginning i was a little bit um i didn't
know how to be around him i was very
uneasy in who what i stood what i
who i was to him and i think it caused a
lot of problems early on but as soon as
i realized like look dude like you can't
chase him he's gonna be the animal that
he is
um
and i mean i could not even talk to him
about little things that i would find in
this house like whether it was
photographs of him like spreading a
woman's ass cheeks open
what like i mean they were hey i just
had to
to learn to like toughen my own skin it
was really weird because i never had to
deal with that it wasn't one of the
girls so many i mean i still keep them
because i can't even throw them away
because it's like well
it's history
it's kind of cool actually it's proof
yeah it is proof that it happened you
threw away that little doll house right
what's in it well the doll house was bad
juju i would put like he had this weird
little pink doll house that always made
me feel oh sarah's
oh that's why i didn't even know it was
i don't dislike her i think she's a
great girl yeah but sarah's dollhouse
was here and it would it was gone the
only reason i got rid of it is because
it had a creepy vibe to it like
something lived inside of it so it had
little windows i would cover with little
index cards yeah because she used to go
to like thrift stores and buy these like
weird [ __ ]
yeah it didn't give me a good feeling
here yeah she's just like yeah but she i
mean you guys you know but she does have
a jacket of mine but i can never ask it
for a bat but i want it back why can't
you just ask for it back because it's
like it's weird isn't it
letter no it's a cool jacket it's got a
[ __ ]
it's got like a [ __ ] lion in the back
it's a green military jacket with a
gigantic lion oh reuters she still wear
it
no i thought she wears at the comedy
store but i saw it yesterday
you know what i mean i don't even know
who this is yeah you do
oh do you know sarah highland not the
girl from modern family but that
yeah i haven't seen her in a long time
yeah yeah yeah she's a good backer now
on sunday she's a friend you know she's
cool yeah yeah that didn't end sorry i
threw her dollhouse i didn't even know
it was herself [ __ ] her doll house
why did you even bring it up now i feel
bad i was just wondering where it was it
has a spirit living inside it she
doesn't even know that come on
spirit
[Music]
you